on behalf to try spread the word about
United Airlines and Special Olympics
shared commitment to build a more
inclusive society Pro Football Hall of
Famer all-time Chicago Bear great first
ballot Pro Football Hall of Famer I must
say Brian Urlacher back on the program
how are you Brian I'm little girl
retiree buddy I'm fine where are you are
you in the desert no I am in Arizona yes
hey dollars a lot of good information
just put out right there yeah just raids
and signings and I was pretty good I
like that little scenario you put up the
Cardinals you know what Brian I mean
that would be like me saying when you
were playing hey man some interesting
tackling you were doing right there
that's what you so good at what you do
that I don't know I don't know why I'm
surprised look Brian that's all I really
wanted out of you doesn't it I mean that
would be something for the Cardinals if
they could pull something like that off
I like Carla Marie I think he's awesome
yeah I think the kids awesome okay what
what do you like about him I like that
he runs really fast
good he seems to be pretty smart was
decision-making with the football and
you look at using the same system Baker
made sure was in I know different skill
sets blah blah blah but and it's just
he's impressive with what he can do yeah
but wouldn't you is a if back in the day
when you were playing hey here comes a
guy who's not even 5 foot 10 comin at
you wouldn't you and the defense say
bring them on as long as you're sitting
down but you got a little 510 guy we ran
at you it's I mean I shouldn't say
little but when you get a fine thing I
run at you it's not easy as people make
it sound attack of those got it so once
you get a hold of them to probably get
them down but it's not easier to you
might figure to get a hold of them hmm
so I know it's a lot of food for thought
because no I took to me Brian this is
this is the moment right now if this kid
is at top 5 top 10 draft choice this
year as we're expecting him to be this
is the in my mind maybe the trance the
complete transformation of the 20th
century or the 21st century of college
football
being brought to professional football
and the spread and the RPO is and all of
that that this would be the full-on
admission from all of the talent
evaluation community even though it just
takes one team to say that it's a whole
brave new world it's different
yeah we're changing yeah you know
announcer this resolution after him you
know I was so happy Baker made to go
after number one I said I wasn't I was
kind of surprised but I I thought he was
the best quarterback in the draft you
know an attic you're out there and
through the addition is it amongst all
the rookies and it played three damn
good not just for the rookie you know
you said in that situation where the
team wasn't very good the year before
and then with a lot of games this year
so I don't see Colin gray being quite
that impactful but man he just that's
what he did last year you gotta think
that look gotta help pallamary situation
a little bit Brian are like a Pro
Football Hall of Famer joining me here
on the show what was the your combat
experience like in 2000 stressful man so
I wasn't gonna run or do anything when I
went there because everyone back in the
home and you know I was like you can't
you should wait to your perlier because
you're gonna run faster you'll be more
comfortable blah blah blah so and then I
got there and I sat in a meeting with
the Bears and Coach Bosco's are you
riding tomorrow I said no sir I'm not I
was advised not to run he goes what do
you got to hide were you not in shape I
said no I was advising our own egos are
you not fast are you can you not do the
drills looks like no I can do them I
just was told on so he goes well I feel
like you're hiding something if you
don't run so of course I went out and
ran the next day thank goodness I did it
was his thought was you know every GM's
here every Scouts here every head
coaches here and then I live interview
Chakotay so this is your best chance to
showcase your abilities and flows of
every single one of them that was Greg
blush right the the Jeff defensive right
yeah right so who is the head did you
have any meetings with the anybody named
McCaskey and I mean who else did you
chat with from the bear you know I don't
know if they were in our meeting or not
you know Marchetti was our GM at a time
coach ron was American Coast Lindsay was
in their bottle off you don't remember
you know at that time everything because
you go from meeting to meeting it's just
it is you know you're trying to answer
everyone's questions properly so I don't
remember I remember coach Schwartz the D
coordinator is he still at Philly yeah
so
he was a DC at Tennessee at the time he
was tough on me man he was asking me
some questions you how could you help
our team why should we draft you do you
we don't know if you'd be able to help
us or not outright I don't know I think
I'm pretty fast I can tackle people did
you get asked any of those crazy ask
questions what's what's the craziest
question you remember that was asked of
you at the combat oh you know the
weirdest thing for me was just walking
around his shirt off all day
well there's 300 guys there and
everywhere everywhere you go no one's
dressed is just weird come on but you
know it's a meat market you know for
those for those two or three hours where
you're doing your weight and your
measurements officer let's just walk
around there sure like a little big deal
you were I guess I was just weird
you weren't flexing Brian come on you
weren't doing you know I'm reflect all
the time I didn't need to flex I was
young and I was no body fat a little
different now but effective that it has
a walk around flexing remember what you
ran I ran a four or five eight or seven
at the combine and I was so happy you
know that was a slow death retrospective
- you should know that with your 40 days
you know there's reporters if you ran
you should well be them how that goes
well my 40 days are still going I
noticed that or that's just me getting
faster Brian but you know that could
just be that I think it's you actually
because it's reply hasn't changed in a
few years I think it's more rich thank
you in a turf I'm a fine wine brother
you knew you know that and in general as
you know I have the aerodynamic dome for
that sort of I don't you think it is but
it could help you a little bit maybe a
temper I'm gonna get into this right now
Brian you know I always enjoy this part
of our conversation and at some point at
some point I'm going to sneak in Jay
Cutler as you know unlike any other okay
yeah I'm actually thinking looking at
primes looking at Dion well he looks
great
looking at you pretty good too actually
I'm actually thinking about it you
should do it you look I mean how did you
look bad at all but my wife tells me I
look younger and it only takes one
person to tell me that and I'm like I'd
be a little younger
and it sir because their opinion matters
to me my kids think I look cool now so
okay it's just different you know what I
mean you know I'm on the air all the
time
you know I knew this way for a while
I've got some great photographs of some
of the great guests that we've had here
for the last four years here on the show
they taught Ematic Lee look dated you
know that's like no brew before before
hair after hair I have the same issues
not a big deal you know just roll with
it it's uh it's a pH rich pretty hair
rich and then you got rich I'm thinking
about Brian I'm not gonna lie oh man
that's good we got you thinking I don't
I know a really good company you should
go to no I know I know it's restored we
could soar
I know Prime's got it - mom loves his
man that dude is always talking about
his hair yes I wanted to get the jheri
curl thing going again he might he calls
himself
what'd he call himself he called himself
to come back player of the year is over
yes all right so tell me what your what
you're up to with the United Airlines
and these special ops Brian it's
different away you know I I was a part
of Special Olympics in college in the
NFL you know I left academia home game
for a special experience
it's something I'm making about the
training camp I did it's something
that's very dear to my heart I think
they do a great job at the Super Ball
table spend some time we did a media day
with one of the special appearance
pre-booker skeezer game Jackie got
college scholarship to run track it was
in school isn't Mauritania seems just a
great success story what she's gone
through and just partnered up with them
to kind of raise awareness about what
unites doing so people's when they have
some challenges in their life yeah
United leading the way in providing a
positive experience for customers with
intellectual disabilities by
implementing new training for employees
and you can go visit hub dot United comm
to learn more about United Airlines work
with Special Olympics
you're good man Brian Urlacher you know
you know you're not a great cover for do
you know I'm just trying to make it
easier for people I hate traveling
personally trying to make it easier at
the airport we're not just people with
intellectual disabilities everyone so
make it easier makes your process to
less stressful you know glaze has been
training me right you know it is Jim
unbreakable there's a mural on the wall
and unbreakable performance and you're
on it that was BR Urlacher before
restore that was B are you BR bra before
restore or lacquer or very good yeah
well not with him but I mean I've been
doing their thing I'm trying to get my
you know my stamina up and I'm getting
my core tight as best I can
so when I run I run fast that's what I'm
trying to do last really wait yeah
you're doing this I have when you great
that I've dropped some lbs over I would
say so I feel great I really do feel
dude that's all right that's all I kind
of rank my workouts how do I feel
another night if I lose weight or
whatever I just wanna know that I still
good what'd you think of the bear season
before I let you go awesome so excited
I'm excited you know it didn't end the
way we wanted to but I'm just having
Witter go in the direction they're going
or get the right coach and they're great
players no I was a captain at the Pro
Bowl and the parents had several guys at
the COBOL so it was a fun week for me
and at the end of honors in coaching
Aggie I coach of the year
I just really excited at the direction
they're going right now yeah I love
their coach I love him I didn't forgive
me he's great he's cool he's my age he's
been on the show I think he's bold not
only in his play calling but in the fact
that he is a bald man and he wears a
visor which only calls more attention to
it Brian but it looks cool we're in the
visor I think what's important about it
looks sweet daughter
it's a thiser in a headset and then a
ball dome no matter the temperature also
exponents and it's a
and I just have you reached out to him
to do restore have you told well you
know I like his look man I think I think
it's written plus with the visor you're
not I can't change that now you know
they have their hat now instead of a
visor to either get hair you know it's
interesting just to bring this all full
circle Brian that you like Kyler Mari a
lot some guy who might not clock in at
five ten when you normally love those
big tall pocket passers playing football
you love those guys with the big arms
he'll just fit it into any window
without conscience guy was mobile and
now it's gone never mind yeah JJ could
make all the throws I didn't see
everything he can make the throws you
can put the ball anywhere guy who takes
responsibility you know afterwards at
the podium you like those guys risky I'm
glad you let me do that right away you
watch the games I'm sure you have rights
because you're always covering the games
of stuff and that's the other
information who do you see give the
credit to where they went
do you know the the line and his
teammates and the defense and when they
lose it's on him it's not him Brian
because I should have played better and
I loved his body language what do you
think of his body language Brian great
funny Mendes it's tremendous it always
stands up well he's personal looks like
a body builder but yeah I always love
our chats great to see you yeah I hope
to see you bet that's Brian Urlacher at
be Urlacher 54 again hub dot United calm
to learn more about his work with United
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience